beneath the waves is a mysterious world
that takes up to 95% of Earth's living
space only three people have ever
reached the bottom of the deepest part
of the ocean the deep is a world without
sunlight of freezing temperatures and
immense pressure it's remained largely
unexplored until now man a depth of 4290
meters as a species we've always
explored
it's just part of our DNA to walk over
the next mountaintop and take that risk
and learn something new now we're just
starting to really explore the last
French here which is ocean at the same
time that we needed cutting-edge
technology is enabling a new generation
of aquanauts to explore deeper than ever
before
if you think for a moment that
everything's been found that there's
nothing left to do here's a place where
it hasn't happened to graduate they are
opening up a whole new world of
potential benefits to humanity the risks
are great but the rewards could be
greater from a vast wealth of resources
to clues about the origins of life the
race is on to the final frontier too
deep
[Music]
[Music]
the Okeanos Explorer the American
government state-of-the-art vessel
designed for every type of deep ocean
exploration from discovering new species
to investigating shipwrecks
on board engineers and scientists come
together to answer questions about the
origins of life and human history when I
was a boy I wanted to be an astronaut
instead I've been in submersible as an
Aquanaut down to the deepest depth look
at this I'm on it on a ship just off the
coast of Hawaii playing with underwater
robotics I mean to me that that's just
awesome
today the Okeanos is on a mission to
investigate the wreck of World War one
submarine dr. Beckmann Decker engineer
Bobby Moore is part of a team who has
developed the technology for this type
of mission we go through check all the
nuts fold hydraulic oil everything make
sure everything works as it should we
don't want to get down to the bottom of
the ocean and find out things aren't
working
we are hands-on involved in these
vehicles from start to finish I mean
when we need a new part we design it
when something breaks we fix it when it
comes to going out on the ship and
operating it where the pilot the deep
discover a remote operating vehicle is
equipped with 20 powerful LED lights and
designs withstand the huge pressure for
miles down equivalent to 50 jumbo jets
stacked on top of a person this vehicle
is equipped to handle all sides of
deep-sea exploration these are brand new
cameras that we got and they're just
phenomenal we get detail that you can
see in a man submersible through a
porthole good decks player deck is clear
copy that we're good we can proceed
in the control room leading the
expedition is Jim Delgado yeah this is
asking guys if keep it up once the chief
scientist mapping the Titanic Jim use
deep-sea exploration as a whole new
enterprise what we're doing is tapping
into the final frontier beneath the
ocean I can boldly go where no one's
gone before I can seek out new life as
well as evidence of past civilization ok
drop in module 8 40-minute dive we can
proceed you guys are ready to drive
here we go
[Music]
she's not my son are in step 31 closer
yep one more notch is 20 copy
[Music]
Merson target could be that
current looks like it's coming
north-south you have maybe bump me in
ten meters
[Music]
we're approaching the stern
[Music]
look at that yeah that's good okay we
are now has a submarine in sight we are
at the stern
on the starboard side
okay we are on the site of f19 World War
one vintage submarine settled in 1938
when you see a ship at the bottom of the
ocean when you understand the human
stories behind it it reminds us that
this is the story of all of us bearing
zero nine zero degrees B decimal 2 I'm
seeing a fair amount of marine worms
growing these wrecks are time stamps for
us in terms of what the ocean does is to
shipwrecks how it works as a platform
for new life for habitation colonization
by marine species move initiated that's
a good copy thank you bridge stop sign
you see that round structure this yeah
let's zoom in on that if you don't mind
it is a plastic plate gently so there we
have it again modern trash I can't think
of the place I go where I don't see
modern trash everywhere okay we're good
here we can keep going while the crew of
the Okeanos send robots to investigate
the deep some of their fellow scientists
prefer a more hands-on approach dr. Greg
stone is a world leading marine
biologist with over 8,000 hours under
the sea he has been exploring the abyss
in person for 30 years we still have
never been able to replace the
experience and what a person can learn
when they're in a submarine at depth
looking out window
as you go down you start brightly-lit
day like so you go down into a Twilight
Zone and it's like Twilight and the
animals are there I'm looking through
the porthole and you look down and it's
darker and darker and darker it starts
to get cold too and then you get below
Twilight in you're in the perpetual dark
room hasn't seen the light of day for
billions of years it's like space
exploration almost we're going where no
one has gone before
that's what I love and you end up with a
very interesting and rich ecosystem
incredible
[Music]
right here yeah oh my god
[Music]
everybody likes to discover new to me
it's always fun and as soon as you get
down into deep sea exactly kind of easy
and that tells you something about the
deep sea we have not been there much
holy crap the technology opening up the
deep is also opening up opportunity not
just to witness the diversity of life
but to glimpse vast amounts of rare
mineral resources some of the world's
most valuable metals can be found deep
under the waves a discovery that has
begun to pique the interest of the
global mining industry the next frontier
for mining is going to be in the ocean
because there's a lot of these rare
earth elements of minerals energy the
boldest of mining companies are heading
to the deep drawn by the allure of a new
Gold Rush
but to exploit it they're also beating a
path to another strange new world
in an industrial estate in the north of
England SMD is one of the world's
leading manufacturers of remote
underwater equipment this is one of our
tipsy mining machines its small
prototype so half the size that you
would see this is a remotely operated
machine it's working up to 4,000 meters
depth in some of the harshest conditions
no we have a saying it's not like a
client it's much more difficult enough
the industrial technology the company
has developed has made mining possible
several kilometers beneath the ocean
surface the top of a gold copper silver
where the metals cobalt and all of those
resources are potentially very valuable
then absolutely necessary for the future
prosperity of humankind with an
estimated 150 trillion dollars worth of
gold alone deep-sea mining has the
potential to transform the global
economy the companies with the permanent
industry will be able to buy whole
country but value is is almost
immeasurable but at what cost
with so much still to discover mining in
the deep ocean could have unknowable
impact there are so many secrets to be
revealed very important and delicate
balance in it we're currently at a depth
of four thousand two hundred ninety
meters an octopus is it looks like it
they have never like ever seen Allan
that's what the third excellent it's not
just life today that may need protecting
reaching the deep ocean might just allow
researchers to answers and truly
fundamental questions hydrothermal vents
hot springs on the ocean floor are
cracks in the Earth's crust
some claim they could help scientists
glimpse the origins of life itself one
of the discoveries of the latter part of
the last century was that there's these
really hot vents coming out of the sea
floor where at 32
group leaders these events have their
temperatures are hundreds of these
degrees Celtics kids been really hot and
they created ecosystems down in the deep
sea that are independent of sunlight
every other life system on the planet as
far as we know depends originally on
sunlight but this did not and one point
we thought hey I wonder if that's how
life started and the question is still
pretty wide open it's just incredibly
exciting we're trying to manage
spaceship earth we're traveling 67,000
miles an hour right now around the front
everything we've ever had everything we
ever will have is here and we need to
Stewart it and figure out how this thing
work how this spaceship work and the
challenge is to manage that system with
us a part of it
so the humanity the modern world and the
natural world can code
[Music]
we might still be years away from
unlocking the mysteries of the deep even
with the latest technology this kind of
exploration is always challenging watch
leave now and for we're major problems
going on we just started to rock tapping
standby fridge are we now we're drifting
sweetie why don't you go wash leave know
what's going on just bloody feet I'm
sorry could you repeat that the ship
lost dB Roger that
okay so all hands we are aborting the
dive we watch GPM
so we're terminating dive on s 19 and
recovering the ROV we had to terminate
because the ship lost his direct
position who couldn't just hold in place
which means you're then taking on
expensive instrument and leaving it to
the mercy of the currents and you don't
want to snag it so they'll have that RV
up on the deck staff
as the clue of the Okeanos comes to
terms with a scale of the challenge and
the opportunity that lies beneath what
they and others discover could transform
humanity's understanding of how to
protect the ocean it's the most hostile
environment on earth but the keys to our
future may lie in the deep
[Music]
you